hallo hier ist herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu seinem neuen video sind ist
alles schön titel eingeblendet nämlich
die beste und letzte star nikki reed ist
euch jetzt vorstellen werde sind nicht
in ihrer reihenfolge aneinander gepackt
oder so sondern wirklich nur solche über
die plattform gegangen und hab mir grad
ok sieben stück suche ich mir erst mal
raus nicht ändern ich werde jede musical
ja doch noch ein bisschen was sagen
warum ich dass sie mit reingenommen
haben und warum ich das so geil finde
oder so gut oder so kreativ oder so toll
boden schreibt ihr bitte in die
kommentare welches musical hier vor den
sieben stück die ich euch zeigen werden
selber am besten findet und lasten
leichter wenn ich sowas auf jeden fall
noch mal machen sondern gemäß musical
dieses musical von christen händler
händler ich weiß immer noch nicht
richtig wie die ausgesprochen wird habe
ich einfach mal zu den besten musicals
ihren diesem video dazu gezogen weil ich
diese stop motion tanzen mega cool
findet hayes saal komplett beschützen
bei mir aus aber deswegen bin ich halt
wie das ultra coolen hingekriegt weil
bei diesem lied halt immer diese bi zu
droppen so unter zusammenhalt perfekt
diese moves machen wenn wir das
innehalten geschwindigkeit abspielt dass
man die hände so haare im nächsten block
und dann irgendwie sondern beim nächsten
macht man irgendwie sondern macht man in
wiso und dann kann man daraus sein gutes
musical die machen es ist also bei mir
bei den besten musicals mit der
rheinbahn ist einfach kreative diese tat
finde ich cool ich finde sie hat super
cool nachgestellt und man sieht dass die
sich damit gedanken gemacht hat
das nächste musical ist von sec gegen
den kennen wahrscheinlich sehr viele aus
irgendwelchen tv werbungen oder von
youtube ich glaube ja sogar der ist mit
youtube groß und berühmt geworden hat
seine musical ist genauso wie seine
instagram videos und youtube-videos
nämlich ultra kreativ und mit
nachbearbeitung mit irgendeiner witzigen
idee und ein musical die macht erst mal
nicht so viel mit ware doch macht es
schon auch aber denn so eins habe ich
nicht ausgesucht weil das kennen glaube
ich jeder an seinem ultra witzige idee
und jeder hätte darauf von köln aber
sich dabei gedanken so ich zeig euch das
mal
man denkt wirklich zu beginn des
musicals pastor wirklich einfach einer
so sitzt und irgendwie ein passend
aufpasst und dann läuft er halt da drum
rum und irgendwann fällt dem zuschauer
auf ok das ist nur ein pappaufsteller
und dann wasser halt auf also ich will
gegen die ultra coole ich glaube
wirklich dass wäre meine
lieblingsmusiker die aus denen aldi ich
jetzt hier ja okay da kommen wir auch
andere kohle
das musical ist auch bei meinen letzten
musicals mit dabei weil es einfach eine
coole idee cri cri dem kriege jetzt das
neue wort für kreative idee ich glaube
ich haben bei dem ersten sieg in die von
christen häntzschel gesagt dass das stop
motion war was christen handshake machte
basiere allerdings manchmal dieser
roboter tanz das hier ist jetzt nämlich
stop motion also stop motion ist quasi
das allen video aus vielen bildern
gemacht wird allerdings nicht aus
30 bilder pro sekunde oder sechs bilder
pro sekunde sondern weniger und der
trainingszeit werden es ist ein
schwieriger aber ich finde die idee
einfach cool sie hat halt irgendwie so
ein blumen obst pfefferminz pflanzen
beet angelegt oder mit dem finger
darüber diese wer diese dinger gedreht
und haben die sich anfangs zu drehen das
ist einfach unser kulig bender soll ich
hier
ich kann ich richtig reden aber ich
zeige euch hier das musical die noch mal
bei den musical diverse jetzt nächstes
teile muss ich wirklich dazu geben es
ist ein stinknormales music idee dass
jeder so hätte machen können die idee es
nicht cool ist keine kreative keine
krise haben wir heute gelernt dessen
freie aber ich finde wer braucht das
profil der leute geht dieses musical
gemacht haben merkt man einfach so eine
krasse positive energie das ist halt
einfach eine familie die nahezu jedes
musicali zusammen aufnimmt und dann ist
es teilweise so dass der vater rhein
kommt ins haus
dann tanzen gerade schon alle zur musik
oder die er macht und handy birthday
song jedes einfach gut drauf
die hauptmotivation die plattform
lisicki hat nämlich dass man spaß dabei
hat konstant zu kreieren genauso wie auf
youtube und das vermitteln diese leute
und man merkt es wieder positiv bei
glaubt deswegen hier nochmal das musical
das nächste musical ist von zwillingen
die jeder kennt
ich kann nicht sagen dass ich dir jetzt
menschen feiern weil ich sie nicht kenne
die sind glaube ich dreizehn oder
vierzehn also noch enormen jutta dieses
bei denen wirklich jedes musik mit einer
durchdachten story wird mit dem roten
faden also hierbei geht es darum dass
hannah montana team wiesing klarere
tauschen oder haare entladen oder
klamotten ändern und die macht genauso
auch auf die kamera zu und haben dann
ein paar andere klamotten also es ist
relativ simpel das ganze selber
nachzustellen aber auf die idee zu
kommen ist cool und ich finde gesetzes
culum sie sind sympathisch ich immer gut
gelaunt deswegen ganz auf mein bestes
musical ist das nächste musical ist von
dieser person
die kennt nämlich alle schon das ist der
kritische und den hatte ich ja schon in
den letzten video von mir zum musical
nämlich irgendwie die dümmste musicals
mit drin
tanz damit seiner schlange oder
irgendeinem anderen reptil in seiner
hand
und da habe ich ein musical von ihm als
tourismus italy deklariert weil er sich
da irgendwie nicht wirklich auf die
lyrics bezog sein aquarium geschafft hat
sich verkleinert aber das bin ich echt
cool ich habe dabei gelacht
so zeige ich euch das mal bin ich aber
nein dass die plattform musicali nicht
nur für irgendwelche musikvideos und
irgendwie sowas genutzt wird sondern
halt auch für comedy ändert mich
dahingehend halt so ein bisschen an
weinen wo ich traurig fand das weinjahr
in deutschland nicht so richtig den
durchbruch geschafft hat aber comedy
bringt uns auch schon zu dem letzten und
was ich auch findet sehr guten user
kenny
dieses musicals vom jackpot und
natürlich musste die grabstelle doch
jetzt video rein weil es einfach
irgendwie ausschlaggebend für musical
ist und daher kennen die plattform
erfolg viele leute und so jack boyle ist
ein amerikanischer comedian der glaube
ich auch auf wein bekannt wurde und mit
facebook ist in diesem ganzen short
content zeigt starfire ich mega diese
ganze amerikanische clique darin wieder
erlauben dann irgendwie kinder als die
pons und die gibts ja das ist eine die
machen einfach leisten konnte es sind
einfach so sind kunden filme die an aber
trotzdem zum lachen bringen und ich bin
einfach entwickle ich damit diese chips
werner gropp challenge komplett hoch
genommen indem er halt er ist das ganz
normal gemacht hat und so halten bilder
von sich gezeigt habe aber dann wie
jetzt heute aussieht und dann mit
sondern kaputten sonnenbrille und mit
irgend einer büroklammer im mund fand
ich sehr cool und hab gelacht
das war ziel von dem video meine damen
und herren wenn es euch gefallen hat
last auf jeden fall leichter und schreib
mir und in die kommentare welches
musical hier am besten fand und auch im
zweiten teil davon haben wollen von
dieser serie werden hier das video bis
hierhin geschaut habe dann schreibt man
die kommentare beste musikvideo
wenn ihr hier oben auf den freudig
können die meinen kanal abonnieren und
hier findet ihr das video die dümmsten
musical ise eingeblendet welches auch
ultra abgegangen ist was ja auch alle
mega gefühlt habe und habe heute
wikileaks gezeigt wurden und sonst bin
ich jetzt raus danke fürs